[Musique]
bienvenue une pluie d'étoilés pour cette
nouvelle édition de paris saclay tv
centrale supélec s'allie à l' agence
spatiale européenne pour créer les à
l'ab la soirée de lancement de ce
partenariat réunit des invités
prestigieux comme la spationaute claudie
haigneré ou encore le physicien etienne
klein paris saclay c'est aussi une étape
incontournable pour le deep tech tour
une tournée des campus français organisé
par bpi france
la banque publique d'investissement
veulent inciter les chercheurs les
doctorants à se lancer à devenir des
stars tupper vous allez entendre les
explications de son directeur général
nicolas dufour et des start up il y en
avait à tech'innove évidemment ce rendez
vous d'affaires est devenu
incontournable au fil des ans
alors cette 14e édition s'est passé à l'
arche de la défense à la donc quitté
effectivement l'essonne
mais l'objectif a été atteint avec 15000
rendez vous professionnel enfin notre
agenda et bien ce sera à la fin de cette
émission
c'est un partenariat prestigieux qui
devrait aller loin très loin dans
l'espace et au delà centrale supélec
s'allie avec l' agence spatiale
européenne pour créer les à l'ab at
centrale supélec
il s'agit d'inciter les étudiants les
étudiantes à s'intéresser à
l'exploration spatiale et à tous qu'ils
sont découlent
et pour lancer ce partenariat une soirée
exceptionnelle s'est tenu ici même avec
des invités prestigieux
regardez
c'est une soirée un peu exceptionnel qui
se tient actuellement sur le campus de
centrale supélec puisqu'on a l'honneur
d'accueillir le directeur général de
lézat de l'agencé spatiale européenne
ian burner d'accueillir également
claudie haigneré etienne klein et ce
plateau prestigieux en fête a été réunie
à l'occasion d'une table ronde que l'on
a tenu dans le contexte de la création
d'un des zarabes c'est à dire d'un
laboratoire en partenariat avec les avec
l'agencé spatiale européenne donc de
centrale supélec l'objectif de lézat lab
c'est de développer en fait des
coopérations en matière d'enseignement
c'est à dire que les a évidemment un
vivier d'experts et puis des
laboratoires des moyens expérimentaux
très important et une idée c'est de la
de profiter de s'appuyer sur ce
potentiel scientifique pour développer
des enseignements développer des visites
sur site des projets avec avec nos
élèves
c'est une reconnaissance et c'est un
honneur pour centrale supélec d'avoir
été choisis par les as pour pour faire
ce partenaire pour établir ce
partenariat et mettre en place c'était
valable
c'est évidemment un processus électif
[Musique]
fort de ses idoles est fort des
spécifiques entre qu'aux tout contact
climate change
les sorties vélo damsels people we weed
nos deux filles
convaincre les chercheurs et les
doctorants de se lancer dans des start
up de s'ouvrir au monde de l'entreprise
c'est le credo de bpi france qui a lancé
un diptyque tour une tournée des campus
français pour appeler aux universitaires
que le monde de demain se crée dans
leurs labos ce tour s'est arrêté ici à
paris saclay nous avons rencontré le
directeur général de bpi france nicolas
dufour
[Musique]
alors je dis petit tour c'est très
simple tout ce que fait de pays france
ont fait sur le terrain comme comme des
forains avec une avec une caravane pour
aller à la rencontre des français
et là au cas particulier on traverse la
france dans 57 ans pour aller à la
rencontre des chercheurs donc les
chercheurs le sacré aujourd'hui c'est ça
le tour alors la deep tech c'est quoi
c'est la science est donc c'est ce qu'on
appelait des technologies fondamentales
la technologie profonde et notre
recommandation aux chercheurs c'est
n'hésitez pas à créer des start up
dans le monde de la science qu'il faut
c'est au fond avoir une connaissance de
le monde de l'entreprise tout même assez
tôt même même éloigné pour le comprendre
et puis ensuite être sur des sites
scientifiques qui sont des sites très
très énervé très collectif très
transparent avec beaucoup d'intelligence
partagée et décide que j'ai envie de
plaider site chaux à haute température
ou à la machine à café en échange des
milliers d'idées parce que c'est de là
que viennent les grandes idées de
création d'entreprise volta tour de
sacrés il a une chance extraordinaire
c'est qu'il ya une masse critique de
chercheurs incroyable les moyens
absolument considérable voilà donc c'est
mener les moyens soir et j'ai envie de
dire que pour aller vers son destin
il faut rencontrer à peu près 1000
personnes par an et où vous en trouverez
forcément une parent qui va vous faire
changer de route à saclay vous pouvez
rencontrer mille personnes par an
je vous emmène à présent à l'arche de la
défense pour tech'innove c'était la 14e
édition de cette convention d'affaires
qui a donc quitté l'essonne pour la
défense cette année une édition tournée
vers l' usine du futur et qui a permis
de caler 15000 rendez vous d'affaires de
nombreuses entreprises & start up du
territoire étaient présentes
une journée 100% business et innovation
qui s'est délocalisé cette année à la
grande arche de la défense organisée
jusqu'à présent en essonne ce rendez
vous rassemble des grands groupes des
pme et des start up
cette 14e édition tournée vers l' usine
du futur a généré près de 15000 rendez
vous d'affaires toute cette technologie
qui sont en fait transverse entre les
filières et qui permettent justement à
des start-up d'émerger en se développant
avec plusieurs donneurs d'ordre dans
différentes filières et d'avoir une
accélération on fait de la mise en
relation durable
parmi les innovations mises en avant
lors de ce salon mobile office un
véhicule de transport collectif
connectés que testeront d'ici six mois
des salariés d'airbus entre parier
l'encours de véhicule dans lequel vous
êtes véhicules et éthiques
qui correspond voilà à 80% je dirais or
on sait qu'on a imaginé rendez vous
annuel des décideurs de l'innovation
c'est aussi l'occasion pour les start up
de nouer des partenariats
plusieurs sociétés implantées à saint
quentin en yvelines étaient notamment
présentes on essaie de voir si on peut
trouver des entreprises qui seraient
prêts à collaborer avec nous pour créer
un concept de jeu un concept de serious
games par exemple qui conviennent à
leurs problématiques d'entreprise nous
avons été en fait inviter au salon
tech'innove lors du scan business day
parce que nous avons reçu le deuxième
prix de l'innovation l'objectif ça va
être de rencontrer un maximum de
personnes pourraient essayer de
développer un maximum de partenariats
au total ce rendez vous a rassemblé 214
start up et plus de 80 investisseurs
voilà c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
on se retrouve très vite
d'ici là restez informé sur le pap est
ce point fr et en regardant tv 78 à très
bientôt
[Musique]